my marty feldman am i a gargoyle what's
what's what's wrong with this
[Music]
first up we're starting with the
incredible angela bassett oh i love
angela i love her
so much
she is so amazing and she said something
that i happen to particularly grab onto
the legendary actress says there's one
compliment that you can just go ahead
and keep harpist bazaar says she hates
it when people say you look so good for
your age
um couldn't agree with her more but
in i always get because i don't know i
don't get the age thing but i get you
look so much better in person and i
think
thank you
and then i'm like
what is that job of the hut on like you
know
my marty feldman am i a gargoyle what's
what's what's wrong with this what do
you think
and this is usually when i'm schlumpy no
hair and makeup so i'm also like oh okay
that's interesting
when we're in love we can all go a
little bananas and buzzfeed just
compiled a list of some of the wildest
things that celebs have ever done for
love oh this should be good i know when
rihanna won the mtv vanguard award uh
drake bought her a billboard to
congratulate her
yes very nice
um this one i like justin bieber wanted
to treat selena gomez to dinner and a
screening of titanic so he rented out
the staples center i like that as one
does i like that
um and then who could forget when pamela
anderson and tommy lee got married to
each other after only four days that's
how much they wanted to show each other
that they were in love
after four days
i got a great love story magic johnson
we all love magic johnson and cookie dad
and his wife they've been married for 30
years for their 30th wedding anniversary
he rented out a ballroom at a hotel with
a table for two with a 12-course dinner
with her favorite band frankie uh
frankie beverly um and so they spent the
night just the two of them dancing in
the whole ballroom and eating i just
thought that was in that sweet i thought
that was so sweet so romantic
first up we've got a colorful fashion
trend anyone can do the wall street
journal reports from the red carpet to
the runway it's all about the head to
toe monochrome that's right you can look
like you just jumped into a can of paint
your favorite color you pick that and
then you assemble accessorize your
playful look by keeping it all in one
range we've got a red mint and orange
with kendall jenner rihanna and j.lo
they're going monochromatic that's how
you do it the guys are on board too a
shade of pink a brown and a mustard on
jake gyllenhall michael b jordan and
jared leto ross would you ever go
monochromatic would i uh you know i do
drew hello
you know i like a fashion risk and i i
live in palm springs when i'm not here
in new york and i wear citron all the
time one of the gentlemen the audience
is wearing a citron green right there
you should see me i'll go to bingo and i
wear citron shirts citron shorts and i
have these little citron slides as well
girl you cannot lose me if you wanted to
i was going to say it sounds like
like roadside yeah yeah i just stopped
at him
dig in a manhole
today we're trying a new healthy salad i
say healthy because i'll think it's that
oh
right it's like the most unhealthy stuff
cheese puffs like every day all right
well this is like a huge recipe from
tiktok it's the hot cheese puffs salad
and now credit where credit is due this
was created by a user named ruth it's
cilantro cucumber lemon juice uh tapatio
or tapatio
potato potato
yeah but people pronounce it different
ways and of course there's hot cheese
puffs now emmy we know you're not into
the spicy stuff yet i do not like spicy
stuff we're gonna have the non-spicy for
you and ross and i are gonna try the
spicy no you put like ranch in it and
then with you normal cheese puffs yeah i
don't get ranch dressing well i think i
think that's the real that's a different
recipe a less spicy one so ours it has
hot cheese puffs in it and and this is
not a salad you're lying to me drew
barrymore
but i'm gonna
let's just like three two one all right
three two one here we go
okay i gotta say that's actually kinda
of good
i'm just eating i'm not eating the
cheese puffs thank you very much uh but
it is seasoning all the cucumber and i'm
here for it mm-hmm i actually like this
really good like legit really good yeah
no this is like how's your emmy is it
good
i mean it's a little office but
[Music]